Speaker 1: Let's go to the phones my friends. We
are going to hear from the most important people
to the show which are the people in the
audience. We do these calls via discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord as a
reminder, you have to request to speak if you
would like to chat with me. Very important in
order to be called on your name must be in the
format of name and location or location and name.
So people with jokes or nicknames or, you know,
obvious stuff like that, you won't be called on.
So typically the names would be something like,
for example, Harry from Columbus, Ohio. That's
the first person to join us today. Harry,
welcome to the show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Indeed. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you beautifully.
Speaker 2: That's pleasant. Last time
my audio was well, it was hacked by
and I have no other way to put it.
Speaker 1: They pronounce it
Antifa. Now it's pronounced Antifa.
Speaker 2: Antifa. My bet.
I always get pronunciation.
Speaker 1: I know. Me too. It's crazy.
Speaker 2: So
you said recently you're back in the
gym now. I want to just say one thing,
please. You said that you run before you left.
Speaker 1: I do. And I'm wondering. I'm wondering
if you're going to tell. I have read that
it's better to lift first, because then you're
at maximum strength and then do your cardio.
Speaker 2: Absolutely. That is. The only tweak
I have. I hear you're hitting the weights. I won't
ask you how or in what specific way. I'll let you
get into that detail when you're ready. Of course.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm ready right now. I mean, I
don't know what you're hearing. Listen, don't tell
me what you enjoy. Listen, I'm not like some kind
of. I'm not reinventing the wheel here. You know,
It's like I have found. I look online and I say,
okay, if I'm doing a mix of cardio and weights
and in total, I want to be doing four days a week.
What's the best mix to do? And it's like, okay,
on this day, do rowing machine and then do arms,
and then the next day you can do legs and then run
or, you know, whatever. It's just like I kind of
just I just try to stay organized in that way.
Speaker 2: Yeah, it's good to have a split. I
think that's what it's formally called. Oh,
you split up? Left your doing. You know,
it seems like you're doing a sort of body
part based split, which is can work for
beginners. I think it's an excellent choice.
Speaker 1: Now, if I weren't the beginning,
when does the split stop? At what point?
Speaker 2: I think when you're when you're
ready to move on to something new, when
you're saying, okay, I don't think this
is giving me the returns, or when you learn new
information, for example, I think is a good way
to learn. Like when I realized, you know, I'm
not really hitting certain muscles that I could,
that's when I, you know, change things up,
started switching from a back barbell squad
to a front barbell squat while you know, you
do have all you got to look for this thing.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, Harry, I'm not
there quite yet, but I do appreciate the
the check in, and I'm going to keep going. Okay.
Speaker 2: Okay. Thanks for taking my call. I just
have one more quick question and answer it as
briefly as you want to. When I listened to your
interview with Patrick back, David, I listen to
the one Sam Cedar had with him last week. I think
you guys both in an excellent job dismantling
his lazy right wing points, I'll put it.
But my question is, how do you have the like
the confidence? Like, I don't want to say like
media training, ask feel to how you approach these
guys, but what do you do mentally to just steady
yourself, keep, keep positive, stay on top of all
your talking points. Counter theirs. What is the.
Speaker 1: I really don't do any special prep. I
just try to have my normal routine for the day.
You know what I mean? So like, don't. Because what
I find is like the Patrick Beck David thing is,
like, in the morning, right? If I shake
up my routine and, like, don't have the
breakfast I would normally have or whatever,
if my routine is thrown off, I won't feel
prepared. So I think it's just like maintaining
my routine, basically, and getting enough sleep.
Now and he's gone. Where did it go? All right.
I hope I hope my answer was satisfactory.